so these masks you can buy this 2 000 of
these masks on amazon for 149 bucks ends
up being seven and a half cents
a mask right i cannot tell you how many
businesses i go to
where i forgot a mask and i'm i'm famous
for losing masks i'm forgetting about
them right i got masks all over the
place
and i'm going my mind says i'm like i
forgot my mask sorry you can't come in
if i had to tell you how many businesses
turned me away because i did not have a
mask i couldn't even tell you by the way
this is not a political message i ask do
you have one of the blue masks to give
me
sorry we don't have it let me get this
straight
seven and a half cents cost you
a hundred two hundred a thousand
five thousand dollar customer and
referrals of other people for me to send
to you
just because you didn't get a couple
hundred masks to give you a front desk
to say
don't worry give it to them yesterday i
went to a spa
and i after the spa i was at oh oh spa
in uh manalapan i believe
after this but i went to the apple store
when i went to the apple store to buy
some ear pods right because i
you know these are famous for losing
these but i like these more than the
earpod pro
and the girls like okay thank you went
into the apple store i like to order
this
she took my credit card she wiped my
credit card
the machine she used she wiped the
machine
she wiped her hands she put the card in
after she put the card in she gave me
the pen
to sign each pen they used they throw it
away
then she wiped the card again and handed
it to me to it with a wipe i'm like
do you guys do this yes we do you've
been trained on this yes
like what a special touch and when i
walked in do you need a mask we have a
mask
of course you're not gonna lose a 149
customer what's the profit margins on
this you think for apple
90 bucks 100 bucks what do you think
this cost to make at the amount of that
so again sometimes people have to
realize it's not about politics
this is about you running a business and
one of the things we definitely cannot
afford to do
is having more small businesses go out
of business
small business owners entrepreneurs
go invest in these masks i'm not i don't
this
i'm not talking to whether you agree
with it or not this
is something where somebody comes in the
last thing you want to lose a business
for is
this seven and a half cents go buy a
couple thousand of these i don't get any
kind of advantages or amazon doesn't
send me money for this go buy it on your
own
get a couple thousand of them when
customers come in if they don't have it
get one of those tongs okay the tongue
you get it here you go
hand it to them great customer comes and
shows responsibilities you get more
business
as as much as this sounds common sense
as much as this sounds common sense
you would be amazed how many people
don't
use this aspect of common sense with
their business today if i'm
if i'm the only one doing going through
this then don't worry about it
if you say pat i've gone through this as
well smash that thumbs up button if you
say pat i haven't experienced any of
this
smash the thumbs down button and i'm
okay with that but uh yeah
so get some of these masks don't say no
to your customers
allow the customers to come in having
said that if you enjoy this video
i also want you to watch video called 10
reasons why companies go out of business
if you've not watched this video
it's probably one of the most detailed
videos i've ever done if you've not
watched a click over to watch a video
10 reasons why companies small
businesses entrepreneurs
go out of business having said that have
a great week everybody take care bye